we also have some breaking news out of
the United States and that's for from
our sister channel NBC News
they are reporting and they're citing
two current senior U.S officials and one
former senior Administration official
and they are saying that the Chinese
balloon you'll remember that Chinese
balloon that flew across the U.S they're
saying it was able to gather
intelligence from several U.S military
sites and that's despite the Biden
administration's efforts to prevent it
from doing so NBC cited the officials as
saying that the intelligence China
collected was mostly from electronic
signals which can be picked up from
weapon systems or include Communications
from base Personnel rather than images
U.S officials not immediately available
for comment on that